Hollywood's biggest stars stepped out on
Monday night in Los Angeles for the
premiere of valerian and the city of a
thousand planets you're running nearly
20 minutes late yeah well time flies
when you're having fun and the fashion
was out of this world that space come on
metal gray just you know trying to go
for it
Rhianna stole the show in a blush
princess gown paired with matching
Manolo Blahnik lace-up heels and Kendall
Jenner showed off her stems in a black
mini dress she's so sweet I'm really
glad that she called me while her bestie
and star of the film Cara Delevingne
stunned in a futuristic sheer metallic
gown by Iris van Herpen beautiful dress
it's know it's part of valerian if you
could take home one outfit from any
character in the film and keep it in
your wardrobe what outfit would that be
I'm gonna say my space suit it was
comfortable I'm not sleeping in there it
was actually you know there was a lot
more comfortable than you would imagine
and you got a birthday coming up in
about a month or so 25 I can say it
because you're so young you know what I
mean how was the best way to celebrate
poor result yes young you'll see I'm
gonna do a nice nice getaway with my
with my girlfriends I've heard of
midlife crisis as her such thing as
quarter
[Music]